destination unknown [ __ ] it's that
time it's that time it's that place it's
the same bat-time of the same
bat-channel
nothing ever changes [ __ ] it's
Monday night there's the pre Church if
you had a [ __ ] up day this is the show
for you to watch right now tonight
tonight you're lucky [ __ ] my kills
[Music]
[Music]
that's how we're doing another Monday
night [ __ ] who the [ __ ] do you
think you're dealing with huh uncle Joey
here taking you to the next level of
[ __ ] doom we're ready for you tonight
- we got the [ __ ] chocolate yum yums
we got the [ __ ] Purple Hearts of debt
we got red ones just in case you don't
want to see a devil but you want to see
the devil we're coming at you from all
directions it's Monday May 1st everybody
is equal today you understand me
everybody nobody made a dime everybody's
equal you got no [ __ ] excuses grab
the gun grab the [ __ ] what's the
stuff you put on the handkerchief and
you put people to sleep chloroform and
go to work [ __ ] Mother's Day
coming and she wants to go to Red
Lobster you understand mom wants to go
to Red Lobster [ __ ] [ __ ] Father's
Day without the [ __ ] of death there's
no mom see I'm saying father's don't do
nothing they squirt some [ __ ] juju
juice out of it big Mama's gotta carry
that [ __ ] baby my ears are itching
that's good luck and [ __ ] that means I
might hit that [ __ ] number them all
or I got a [ __ ] roach live in my
Inlet oh [ __ ]
taking it to the next level [ __ ] I'm
happier here I'll have to tell you
[Music]
welcome a [ __ ]
so that we are another fun-filled
evening we got some tremendous reefers
for you
we got this one they contain that came
from Bakersfield Thursday night thank
you
tremendous [ __ ] stupendous it's been
in the car since Thursday night oh [ __ ]
it's nice and dry as usual we got the
Holocaust orgy killing [ __ ]
that's the [ __ ] I smoked this morning
I'd take a nap at 3 o'clock you can't
you can't take it you can't take this
Holocaust oh gee I'm sayin
next thing you know you're eating bagels
and whatnot and the [ __ ] whatever this
is Caspar og coming at you what do you
feel like doing let's do a little [ __ ]
it let's do a little Holocaust RG to get
the party started right to get the SPD
so small shot in the [ __ ] room you
understand cuz the most important thing
when you get this at the SP those models
out of the room it's not you sometimes
the spirits that were there before you
contaminate the place with their [ __ ]
whatever the [ __ ] they drop and whatever
stupidity they're dropping oh [ __ ] it's
time to smoke some reefer break off the
books we're gonna scholastic to my
cottage like this boom you can't hold on
too long it's alright you see that they
got the new Chiba choose and great for
some yeah oh [ __ ]
[Music]
leaves gotta eat kind of those don't
wait but they save that for next week
and Buffalo do we we got the purple a
weekend with Joey's TVs oh yeah yeah eat
sativas cuz that gives a [ __ ] what I'm
gonna give you you're not gonna [ __ ]
believe it's why one of these things
they're blueberry with chocolate around
a nice [ __ ] Laluna brands you
understand me is it time for another
[ __ ] bong hit or what we're doing we
what the [ __ ] you doing over the eighth
one little chocolate you're gonna drink
them water and regurgitate it's alright
you can't hold on too long it's alright
here we go
this [ __ ] is a little guitar
player from Long Island and the cars
Jesus Jesus Christ he just shreds that
[ __ ]
Steve run is easy in the house when I
talk about books tonight they totally
that's your cue [ __ ] this my man
speedrunners easy take another sound he
smoked this weekend he's in training
beautiful you ready to go they come over
him
it wasn't jump he was out of town that
weekend a lot of people he was in
Kentucky with some black chick he's a
[ __ ] [ __ ] but he took the blame
you can't use black people as a [ __ ]
witness and you showing up with [ __ ]
Swami salami let's do this [ __ ] Lee do
this [ __ ] this is like [ __ ] this is
like this is like [ __ ] keep it going
there you go you're in training it don't
matter if the eyebrow burns you got
another one who gives a [ __ ] let's go
breathe breathe there you go is a
monster
there you go it's the [ __ ] that's the
paper deck right there see how we do it
here the trains everybody's ready to go
for war you if Putin comes over here
with bong hits he ain't doing no damage
and uncle Joyce voodoo [ __ ] loud
looking already Lee and that's leaving
the Holocaust og last time I spoke the
Holocaust urge a three [ __ ] bagels
you understand who's on the town [ __ ]
it's over we got stars we got every Oh
let's bust out those [ __ ] stars here
it's that type of party understand some
people by the three-pack I go with the
50 pack but you never know when you got
a bum and off the bat [ __ ] we're
not trying to [ __ ] around here and check
it out we still got the earthquake bag
just in case well prepared she's only in
the 70s you had like the [ __ ] Tang
Tang powdered milk some SpaghettiOs
we don't even worry about that [ __ ]
we'll just we'll just take over 7-eleven
down the corner well bust the [ __ ]
windows they'll be like la 94 is to the
[ __ ] Koreans will be Hindus will be
kicking them up to block the magnolias
hi friend Easter Roberts eight kids
that's right that's a good idea I never
taught her that you got a Robin
earthquake cake people I'm saying when
you watch the show it's as entertaining
as educational mmm oh yeah oh yeah I'm
like PF uh Cal appeal here it's so
interesting I saw that film the director
was a bit off was it what is it with his
interpretation of what an exorcism look
like what a [ __ ] to you
who the [ __ ] to you be the star
[ __ ] this is like this is like
[ __ ] the Allman Brothers
I need a peach sweet let's do this one
two three four five six seven eight nine
and two for good luck like [ __ ] star
Lee you don't say 2,200 on a Monday
night what did you do what did you do to
it what the [ __ ] is like a soldier on a
[ __ ] Monday night it's a dark [ __ ]
purple red yeah
Aniki [ __ ] star one also puts [ __ ]
a little red vino in there it's good for
the heart no I gotta put some food in
here in case there's an earthquake
cashews tang [ __ ] like that nobody
remembers [ __ ] thang you [ __ ]
you would eat every mess
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we're training hit people understand and
if you on they teen hang up now
right [ __ ] now [ __ ] two weeks
ago some uncle [ __ ] contacted me join
my son's doing Aaron watching that's
your problem
don't put that on me the return Ari
Shaffir them off he's back to [ __ ]
punch drunk right the return of the
[ __ ] Man of Steel the original Johnny
commercials Johnny commercials
he was killing those [ __ ] commercial
he would even want to do them they were
given to leave this weed I'm gonna give
you one
tickets to the Dodger game on ESPN Radio
that day so I told them I go let's go as
well the way they were gonna throw this
commercial you want to graduate yeah we
sign in right
they call us them together all three of
us we 22 re and somebody got a little
you - aren't you jealous BBQ for a
minute I come over I'm jelly and Ari
does it pause just turns and looks at me
go ooh and knocks me Dex me on the
ground real slash to the ground
what happened um it was my first
reaction he's not gelling and I won the
crap and he's like do you know him holy
[ __ ] man what's up Oh Lee keep beat what
do you listen for goes on alright let's
keep it this time you know so much slap
that's all same intention just don't
slap it so then we do the current I get
the call back right
they don't call Ari back but we go to
the game and already gets up on the
jumbotron because I'm gonna be on the
jumbotron in three seconds three seconds
later the shirt comes off it starts
doing this three seconds later he's up
on the jumbotron like this shirt off
bouncing around you see what happens
sometimes you need a punch to the head
to say Lee how many stars you got left
five months five more stars oh my god
come in take a bump it give you a little
break
this is the wheeler death over here come
on over this is the [ __ ] Hong Kong
Phooey here little bees regurgitate this
[ __ ] let's do this Lee I'm giving you a
brief of five stars you'll need three or
one and two it the other just look at
he's still drinking water we go on
Vietnam how much what are you sometimes
the bong get stuck you're gonna oh [ __ ]
or can I take you out for a while now
[Music]
she loves those Jews oh she loves those
Jews
[Music]
yeah let's do this
200 milligrams apiece on those [ __ ]
stars I really already feel a melting in
my body you don't eat them for a few
days you can feel them down
oh [ __ ] Lee this is the one this is the
one hold on don't bring it back bring it
back keep breathing and there you go
there you go that's the one that girls
want me to say man that's the one that's
the one that's the one that killed Swami
from salami you understand me
the bonds we got here that mule kicks
harder than any fell let me get that
barley this mule is top-notch I don't
hate it
I don't know why he may not understand
but I don't give a [ __ ] my compliments
whoever made the real
[Music]
that's wrong
I think I'm smoking cuz it's weakness
that's the [ __ ] Jesus game before they
went into the tunnel I go out of my way
you know I can't leave Oh Dame yeah the
other chubby gay dude goes out of his
way to find good food I go out of my way
to find [ __ ] tremendous weight like I
pipe like three guys that they've been
smoking for 40 years I trust him when
they call me like the one I do with this
I'll give you a bump into this he told
me to put scotch tape over the eyeball
cuz he lost his eye this is the [ __ ]
from [ __ ] Israel no way it's real
it's over it's over one is real baby boy
yeah you [ __ ] have no clue when
Israel Cuba they connect with a [ __ ]
bridge forget about it you guys have no
[ __ ] idea what's brewing in the
political storm you're over there I'm
worried about North Korea light and
[ __ ] duds them dumb [ __ ] you gotta go
hang out with the [ __ ] Chinese if you
want your [ __ ] to blow up I'm saying
yeah like [ __ ] guts
you gotta get you know invented the
Firecracker shiny people and you're up
there [ __ ] North Korea [ __ ]
blowing duds you should be ashamed of
your son Hey look at Li the spots are
out on the table a little bit
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] it's the Steve Rannazzisi our
this is the [ __ ] right there oh yeah
this is the studly leaf spots are coming
up he's got a spot over is it like the
old prison or Russia
yeah what's together what Morley come on
bumpit tear down that wall we [ __ ] yeah
we're tearing down the wall bring it
over here with me you smoking forget the
Stars kill this this is it trying to
tell you from [ __ ] like 22
witnesses just in case people die in
here flip the [ __ ] album here I'm
telling you I don't know who this is
please if you invented this mule get a
hold of
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] it's that type of
night if you're in yen if you're not go
get coffee maka chinos over there talk
to some of your buddies yeah with sperm
cappuccinos buddies they're gonna
they're gonna go here and there and save
the [ __ ] world suck my dick it all
starts in your heart right here at the
Voodoo [ __ ] lounge I'm so high
I
you have to flip the album give me a
minute some of my lovely she's a
beautiful girl she is oh [ __ ]
a little can do 79 the [ __ ] cars
dropping knowledge as far as I'm
concerned this was their best album and
their last good out but a little [ __ ]
my I'm just a fat [ __ ] with a few
felonies chilling out with a little Jew
and a man named brothers easy and I'm
saying [ __ ] book of the club month
we're here tonight did you bring a book
and bring one I brought a book always
always come prepared you like Tony ask
awfully sudden brim and then bring it
with me but it's close by but it's close
by [ __ ]
I can have it here in three minutes
besides that it's a flip flip type at
night you Mexican Mormons I'll see you
Friday
for Cinco DeMayo I know there's a few
Mexican Mormons you Mormon [ __ ]
get a Mexican made next you know that
you're trying to [ __ ] one el culo and
you make a one of your wives you put her
in the barrio
nobody knows none next thing you know
you got a brown baby at the Reunion you
don't want to hang out with them who is
that kid get the [ __ ] out it wise guys
comedy club Friday night Saturday night
two shows Golden State's in town
Saturday it's us [ __ ]
bring your Weaver bring your mushrooms
wiseguys common in the following week
I'm at the Turner ballroom Milwaukee the
home of Jeffrey Dahmer and that's it him
same I think of Milwaukee I think a
Jeffrey [ __ ] Donna I also think about
Kent Benson will he play for the
Milwaukee Bucks he he elbowed Kareem
abdul-jabbar in the opening game of the
78 season and Kareem abdul-jabbar ponch
them in the [ __ ] head harder than what
you could imagine you understand
but besides that I'll see you
[ __ ] up there if not Utah I'm
coming in deep bring the reef for Friday
night bring the explosives bring the
clip so you get a [ __ ] from a [ __ ]
celebrity over there at the [ __ ]
festival going over there roofie in
those [ __ ] sandwiches and that's it I
love you [ __ ] youtube.com slash c
/ Joey Diaz is that it youtube.com slash
c / Joey Diaz Steve run is easy my man
Lisa at ten minutes will be ready around